Can I just say, Mr. Barkley got jokes.
He just said to me. Gayle sounded out.
Well, come back. Was that okay?
That was good.
Okay. Welcome back.
Right before the break, you heard us
asking people about aliens.
That's because Congress
just passed legislation
directing the government
to release the records
that it gathers on UFOs
within 25 years of collection
We can think of
nobody better
to talk about this with world
famous astrophysicist.
What's your name?
Neil deGrasse Neil deGrasse Tyson.
He's the author of the new book,
bestselling author, we should say.
The book is called To Infinity and Beyond
and director of the Hayden Planetarium.
That's right here in New York City.
We are so glad you're here.
So we ask viewers to call in, Neil.
And one of the most popular questions
was dangerous.
You know, you go ahead. Really? It is.
Well, that's why I did.
That's why we taped the call.
Please let him come on TV last night.
But we would. We would.
But this is one of the most
popular questions. Go for it.
Hi.
My question is, do you
believe aliens exist in our universe
and is that for me?
Yes, that question is for me.
So I reserve the word believe for topics
like religion and other things
where you just say yes or no.
Not because not all questions
have yes or no answers.
You have been warned.
None that I couldn't otherwise explain
by natural causes as being earthbound.
Yeah, you
things that looked very odd to me.
But I
but I know a lot about the sky,
about weather,
about climate, about lightening, about so
and where Venus is in the sky,
what blimps look like in twilight.
There's a lot of things
that if I didn't know all of that,
I might confuse them for something
exotic or extraterrestrial.
So seems like a very long answer to me.
That is such a simple question.
Okay, I'll give you.
Here it is. You ready? Wait,
wait.
You believe in aliens? No, you don't.
I haven't seen one. Okay.
But I presume you can know
something is true.
Even if you haven't seen it.
Somebody else That's a good point, Neil.
First of all, that's not a good point.
It is.
You are not the measure of what it is.
Well, somebody else would have told me
hey. Hey.
But you're also knocking on your door.
Are you?
What do you say? Take me to your leader.
They're going to come to you.
No, no.
I just want to say this.
Well,
I told you it was an honor
and a privilege to meet you. Okay.
But if we had a person who met the alien,
we wouldn't have you over here.
Okay.
So let me just say. But I.
But I agree with you.
I don't think you have to have seen
something to know that it is right. So.
So it's not about a belief.
It's about evidence.
All right.
Is there evidence?
How compelling is the evidence?
Do we need more for it to reach
a tipping point
where a skeptical scientist
would say there's good evidence for you?
We're all in on this.
Well, science is always evidence based.
So is evidence ways.
Okay, so
what we know
is that the ingredients of life on Earth,
if you break it down atom by atom
were hydrogen. Oxygen.
That's the water, H2O.
We got carbon nitrogen.
Those are the most common
chemically active ingredients
in the universe.
Earth was opportunistic
in its early moments,
going from the primordial goo to life.
Opportunity still trying to figure out.
Is there evidence that there are aliens?
No, there's no.
Not evidence
that would
convince a skeptical scientist.
No. No.
There are people holding their hand up,
swearing to tell the truth. In Congress.
That's not how we establish
objective truth and science.
We don't walk
into a scientific conference and say,
I swear this is true,
but give me a book I can swear on.
That's not how we do this.
You bring out the evidence.
They did this in Mexico.
They brought it.
Put the aliens on display in Congress.
If we have aliens,
that's what they should do.
If they're trying to say
we've got them in a lock box
now in Mexico,
the next step is you take tissue samples
and send it to other labs.
Yeah.
It's not just because one person
and one lab said something is true.
That's not what establishes
the moving frontier
of the objective truth of science.
So any scientist
who looks at the universe,
they say this probably life out there
in the universe.
I can't wait to find it. Yes.
Listen, I've never seen an alien either,
but I just find it hard to believe
that we are the only ones on this planet.
I do believe you hear all the talk
about UFOs. I do think they exist, too.
But I can't believe we're the only ones.
Just to be clear,
if there's something in the sky.
You don't know what it is.
It's called an airplane.
If you're.
Of course, it's a UFO left to. To you.
That's what you stand for. Yeah.
You don't know what it is that does it.
And you just said
you don't know what it is
because you just called it a UFO.
That does not then allow you to say.
I don't know what it is.
Therefore, it's
visiting curious aliens in the sky.
I'm dreaming in the sky.
Yeah, yeah, visiting our skies.
Plus,
there's 6 billion smartphones
in the world,
each capable of high resolution photos.
And videos.
If we were being invaded by aliens,
that would have been crowdsourced
long ago,
and it would have been on the Internet.
We have cat videos
go viral on the Internet.
You know,
if people had aliens
flying near their airplane,
that would go viral, too.
Thank you, Gale.
There's a million people in Google
any moment who are airborne.
You're welcome, Charles.
It's a nice window
right out the side of their airplane.
Okay.
Why is it that all the aliens
are visiting Navy pilots
in restricted airspace? Airspace?
I got this question for you.
Yeah. What's that?
And it just kind of confirm
how stupid men are. Yeah.
And I'm very proud to be a man. Okay.
They have
a list of who could land a plane.
Yeah, there is a poll.
Yeah.
46% of men said it.
Not a women's
who are always smarter than men.
Only 20% of them
said they could land a plane
in an emergency.
Okay, so let me.
I think.
I think what's going on in
the guy's head is I can be talked
down to land this plane.
If I have someone tell me,
okay, not to just come out there
with no with no advice.
So I bet the men are thinking
I could do this
if I have help from, from from
from the airport,
I would like
some women are thinking
that the question means
can you just land a damn plane?
I bet that was the question, though.
But the question was
if you
if there was an emergency,
could you land the plane?
The question wasn't
if somebody talks you through it.
No, I don't agree.
But I think the men are thinking
that's how they
because that's how we see it
in all the movies.
That's how they
probably do it
in the liberties of the
being a big crash in into burning
so damn fast.
Listen,
Charles, even if
somebody is talking you through it,
if somebody was talking,
I think I could land a plane.
If I'm talking to you,
one of the smartest people in the world,
not the rest of the people
dummies out here.
No, seriously.
I do think, Charles,
if somebody was talking you through it,
do you think you could do it?
Well,
I think if it is to pull the lever,
I just want to push the button.
I want to have some look at the knob.
You can't do that.
Everybody
put your back on the basketball court.
Trust my mother up here,
and I want to be back out.
See, I think in real time, what?
They don't understand. Yeah.
Even somebody talking you through it
in real time, you're breaking it.
Focus and function like that.
Now, if you got this break.
Yeah, I believe that.
What a regular person you like.
Well, push this lever, like,
lose a lot of levers, a
switch off.
So the real
answer in this being 23.20, 24,
the real answer is yes.
You push autopilot
and that'll land a plane all by itself.
All right.
New pilots are like for show
at this point,
given what planes do all by themselves.
That's why you
that's why we will get paid.
I just want you to know
as much as I like to respect you.
If we had a person on here who got aliens
they're going.
We're going to get you'll see them.
Say thank you, Neal.
Thank you.
Just get another seat on the head with.